I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi, you guys. We have a very exciting episode today. It is season four, episode 15, Night Out. Yeah, we traveled. We went on the road. There was locations and tons of extras. This was a big production for us. Very little happens in The Office. That's right. Well, this was written by Mindy Kaling,
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨，你们好。今天我们有一集非常令人兴奋的内容。这是第四季第15集，《夜生活》。是的，我们去旅行了。我们上路了。有很多外景和大量的临时演员。这对我们来说是一次大制作。《办公室》里发生的事情很少。没错。嗯，这一集是由敏迪·卡灵编剧的，
directed by Ken Whittingam. And today we have a surprise. I'm not reading the summary again today. Jenna's gonna skip out on her duties. Sorry. Geez. I mean, I know. Was I throwing you shade a little bit? Skip out. Well, we have a super fan who wanted to read the summary. For today's episode, it's Terry Carnation. Terry, welcome. Thank you so much for having me. I am a huge fan, as you previously stated, of Office Women podcast, and you, Jennifer Fisher, and Angel. Everything that you guys do and this show, which is just so hysterically funny. This episode, in particular, I'm so thrilled to be summarizing for your
由肯·威廷汉执导。今天我们有一个惊喜。我今天不会再读剧情摘要了。珍娜要放弃她的职责了。抱歉。天哪。我是说，我知道。我刚才是在暗讽你吗？放弃。好吧，我们有一位超级粉丝想读摘要。对于今天的这一集，他是特里·卡内申。特里，欢迎你。非常感谢你们邀请我。正如你们之前所说，我是《办公室女士》播客的超级粉丝，也是你们，詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉尔的粉丝。你们所做的一切以及这个节目，真是太搞笑了。这一集，我特别激动能为你们的
listening pleasure. Well, we're happy to have you, Terry. Yes. Thank you. Angela, not Angel, but I appreciate. Of course, Angela, but you are an angel. After all, let's not forget. Oh, excellent. Well, should I jump right in, Office Women? Please, let's do it. Excellent. This episode is entitled The Night Away, and it is an excellent episode that features James Halpert and his wife, Pamela, and they are striving to consummate their relationship. And apparently, there's a young fellow named Dwight Scruti and his best friend, Scott Michael, they are running across New York City in this episode. It seems that Ryan has gotten into a little
听觉享受做总结。好吧，我们很高兴有你，特里。是的。谢谢。安吉拉，不是安吉尔，但我很感激。当然是安吉拉，但你毕竟是个天使，别忘了。哦，太棒了。好吧，我可以直接开始吗，《办公室女士》？请吧，开始吧。太棒了。这一集名为《夜生活》，这是一集精彩的剧集，讲述了詹姆斯·哈尔珀特和他的妻子帕梅拉，他们正努力圆房。显然，有一个叫德怀特·斯鲁特的年轻人和他的好朋友斯科特·迈克尔，他们在这一集中跑遍了纽约市。看起来瑞安陷入了一点
trouble with the devil's candy. And by that, I mean that fierce little lady, cocaine. Terry, I have a question. Have you seen this episode? I haven't seen this episode in particular. I have seen an episode of this show, and this is my theory, if I may share it with you, too. About the office? The building is possessed. Why else would the people inside it act the way they do? Why would this delightful Pamela fall in love with that floppy-haired misfit? James Halpert, it makes no sense. People behaving in just absurd ways. The building is possessed. The building itself may be a demon, and Dwight Scruti himself may be some kind
麻烦，和恶魔的糖果有关。我的意思是那个凶猛的小姐，可卡因。特里，我有个问题。你看过这一集吗？我没看过这一集。我看过这个节目的一集，这是我的理论，如果我可以和你们分享的话。关于办公室？那栋楼被附身了。不然里面的人为什么会那样行事？为什么这个可爱的帕梅拉会爱上那个头发乱糟糟的怪人？詹姆斯·哈尔珀特，这毫无意义。人们的行为如此荒谬。那栋楼被附身了。那栋楼本身可能是一个恶魔，而德怀特·斯鲁特本人可能是什么
of dibbick or homonculus. You think there's paranormal activity? In fact, several members of the office might be from hell. I am here merely to speculate. I am saying that perhaps there is a story underneath the story. Yes, this is a light comedy about co-workers. Hardiharhar. But underneath it all, there may be something far more nefarious. Wow. Terry, how many episodes have you seen? Just the one? I am planning on starting to watch this show as soon as we finish this podcast, because it is bewitching me. It has bewitched me. Okay, so you haven't seen any episodes then? I have not, and have you listened to any episodes of
恶灵或人造人。你认为有超自然现象？事实上，办公室里的几个人可能来自地狱。我在这里只是推测。我是说，也许故事背后还有故事。是的，这是一部关于同事的轻喜剧。哈哈。但在这背后，可能隐藏着更邪恶的东西。哇。特里，你看过多少集？就那一集？我打算在播完这个播客后就开始看这个节目，因为它让我着迷。它让我着迷。好吧，所以你还没看过任何一集？我没有，你们听过任何一集
Dark Air with Terry Carnation? No, you have not, so we're even Steven. Okay, well, I don't think... I think we've... That show, Even Stevens, I have watched every episode of Even Stevens. Okay, well, Terry, I think there might have been a miscommunication with your agent. Big fan, huge fan. Thank you so much for having me, office women, and all of the listeners. Thank you for enjoying this show in these two delightful young women, as they share their inner torment with you on a weekly basis. Thank you, Terry Carnation, and I'm sure everyone will want to check out Dark Air. It's gonna premiere April 1st on Audio Boom. Terry, we'd love to
《特里·卡内申的黑暗空气》吗？不，你们没有，所以我们扯平了。好吧，我不认为……我想我们……那个节目，《Even Stevens》，我看过每一集。好吧，特里，我想你的经纪人可能沟通有误。大粉丝，超级粉丝。非常感谢你们邀请我，《办公室女士》，以及所有的听众。感谢你们欣赏这个节目和这两位可爱的年轻女士，因为她们每周都在与你们分享她们内心的折磨。谢谢你，特里·卡内申，我相信每个人都会想去看看《黑暗空气》。它将于4月1日在Audio Boom首播。特里，如果你开始看这个节目，我们很乐意
have you back if you ever start watching the show. If you watch an episode, let us know. I really should do that. It looks fascinating. Well, thank you, Terry. There is one young, accountant-blonde woman who I find very intriguing. Oh, boy. Really? Fictionally speaking. Thank you for having me, office women. Thank you, Terry. Goodbye, Terry. Goodbye. Lady, he'd never seen the show. I don't. He had no idea what we were talking about. He also sounded suspiciously like Rainn Wilson. He really did. He really did. He called me Angel. Well, that was an adventure. We tried something new. That was exciting and confusing. I feel like we have some phone calls to make
让你回来。如果你看了某一集，告诉我们。我真的应该那样做。看起来很迷人。好吧，谢谢你，特里。有一位年轻的金发会计女士，我觉得非常有趣。哦，天哪。真的吗？从虚构的角度来说。谢谢你们邀请我，《办公室女士》。谢谢你，特里。再见，特里。再见。女士，他从来没看过这个节目。我不知道。他根本不知道我们在说什么。他听起来也极其像雷恩·威尔逊。他真的很像。他真的很像。他叫我安吉尔。好吧，那真是一次冒险。我们尝试了一些新东西。那既令人兴奋又令人困惑。我觉得我们有一些电话要打
after we're done. Yeah, I feel like we're gonna text some people. All right, should we get into this episode? Should you actually read a summary? I'd be happy to. A lonely Michael and Dwight go to New York City to party with Ryan and meet ladies. In the meantime, the Scranton employees work late to avoid working over the weekend, but they wind up getting locked into the Scranton Business Park. And Terry did get this part right. Ryan may have a drug problem. Oh, man. Yeah. What are your fast facts? Here's a fast fact for you, Ange. I thought we could do a little breakdown of our guest star, Troy Underbridge. This is his second
在我们结束之后。是的，我觉得我们要给一些人发短信。好了，我们开始讲这一集吧？你真的要读摘要吗？我很乐意。孤独的迈克尔和德怀特去纽约市和瑞安聚会并结识女士。与此同时，斯克兰顿的员工加班以避免周末工作，但他们最终被锁在了斯克兰顿商业园。特里确实说对了这一部分。瑞安可能有毒品问题。哦，天哪。是的。你的快讯是什么？给你一个快讯，安吉。我想我们可以简单介绍一下我们的客串明星，特洛伊·安德布里奇。这是他第二次
appearance on the show. You guys know he first showed up in the deposition. He is played by Noel Petok and we reached out to him. Yes, we did. And Noel was so sweet he sent in a bunch of audio clips and he had some fun stories to share with us. Well, the first thing we wanted to know, we asked a lot of our guests, how did he get the job on the office? And here's what he had to say. Hello office ladies. This is Noel Petok and I don't recall really Alison Jones ever having the audition. I actually started the whole process doing background through central casting. So I did, I think just one episode where I did background, I
在节目中露面。你们知道他第一次出现在证词那一集。他由诺埃尔·佩托克饰演，我们联系了他。是的，我们联系了。诺埃尔非常贴心，他发来了一堆音频片段，还有一些有趣的故事要和我们分享。嗯，我们想知道的第一件事，我们问过很多嘉宾，他是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？这是他要说的。你好，《办公室女士》。我是诺埃尔·佩托克，我不记得艾莉森·琼斯真的让我试镜过。我实际上是通过中央选角公司开始做背景演员的。所以我做了，我想只有一集我做了背景，我
was not really goofing off but acted like I was kind of goofing off, texting on a phone. I was kind of the posse of Ryan, EJ Novak's character and had a good time doing it. I mean, just enjoyed the process and later down the line, I had gotten a phone call from the assistant director and she said she had spoken to Alison Jones and asked me if I'd like to appear on a couple episodes here and there. But I didn't actually audition, they just kind of offered me the role and I gladly accepted. So Angela, when I was a struggling actor, I did tons of background work in the hopes that someone would sort of discover me and give
并不是真的在偷懒，但表现得像是在偷懒，在手机上发短信。我算是瑞安，也就是BJ·诺瓦克角色的随从，做得很开心。我是说，只是享受这个过程，后来我接到了助理导演的电话，她说她和艾莉森·琼斯谈过了，问我是否愿意在这里和那里客串几集。但我实际上并没有试镜，他们只是给了我这个角色，我很高兴地接受了。所以安吉拉，当我还是个挣扎的演员时，我做了大量的背景工作，希望有人能发现我并给我
me a speaking role. It never happened. It's super rare, but it did happen on our show. I mean, that's literally how Creed ended up becoming a series regular on our show. He started doing background work and it's just something that I kind of like about our show. Yeah, me too. And this was also true for some of our warehouse employees that really just started as background characters and then as years went by, they got to have speaking parts. And as an actor, that is so thrilling. But I love that Noel was there and that they went on to use him in several episodes. Well, that was due in large part to Mindy Kaling and he
一个有台词的角色。这从未发生过。这非常罕见，但在我们的节目中确实发生了。我是说，这简直就是克里德最终成为我们节目常驻演员的方式。他开始做背景工作，这正是我们节目中我喜欢的一点。是的，我也是。对于我们的一些仓库员工来说也是如此，他们确实只是从背景角色开始，然后随着时间的推移，他们有了台词。作为一名演员，这太令人兴奋了。但我喜欢诺埃尔在那里，而且他们后来在几集中使用了他。嗯，这在很大程度上要归功于敏迪·卡灵，他
actually talks about that in this next audio clip. Mindy wrote this episode. So here's what he had to say. There is most definitely one person I'd like to thank who actually, I believe, wrote my character originally. And that is Mindy who came up with the character and she kind of came through in the office and ended up getting her on show. And Mindy is incredible. She's so sweet and smart. And I've got to thank Mindy for writing up this character, which was a blast to play. So sweet. I love that. Me too. Well, we have even more audio clips from Noel that we're going to share later in the show. And he
实际上在下一个音频片段中谈到了这一点。敏迪写了这一集。所以这是他要说的。绝对有一个人我要感谢，我相信她最初写了我的角色。那就是敏迪，她想出了这个角色，她通过办公室，最终有了自己的节目。敏迪太不可思议了。她太贴心、太聪明了。我要感谢敏迪写了这个角色，演起来真是太棒了。太贴心了。我喜欢这个。我也是。嗯，我们还有更多诺埃尔的音频片段，我们稍后会在节目中分享。而且他
is just the nicest guy. It was so nice to get to reconnect with him. Yeah. All right, my lady, what is your next fast fact? My next fast fact is a location breakdown because we got some fan questions from Abby, Lana and Natalie, who would like to know was this episode filmed in an actual nightclub. And Mariah Kay asked, are they different clubs? You know, the guys go to two different clubs. Yeah, yeah. Did we film in different locations or is it just two rooms in the same building? Well, I'll tell you guys. Tell us. In the episode, Michael and Dwight and Ryan and Troy, they go party at clubs in New
真是个最好的人。能和他重新联系真是太好了。是的。好了，我的女士，你的下一个快讯是什么？我的下一个快讯是外景介绍，因为我们收到了艾比、拉娜和娜塔莉的粉丝提问，她们想知道这一集是在真正的夜店拍摄的吗？玛丽亚·凯问，那是不同的俱乐部吗？你知道，那些家伙去了两个不同的俱乐部。是的，是的。我们是在不同的地点拍摄的，还是同一个建筑里的两个房间？嗯，我会告诉你们的。告诉我们。在这一集中，迈克尔、德怀特、瑞安和特洛伊，他们去纽约市的俱乐部聚会。这些俱乐部场景都是在洛杉矶市中心的爱迪生夜店拍摄的。现在，爱迪生夜店非常大，他们有几个不同的房间，他们把它们装饰成看起来像两个不同的俱乐部。所以我们只去了一个地点，我们一次性完成了所有拍摄，他们用所有的背景演员填满了俱乐部。但是，安吉，爱迪生其实有一段非常酷的历史。那个夜店？是的。你去过那里吗？我不仅没去过那里，我甚至没听说过它，而且我在洛杉矶住了20多年了。如果这能说明我的时尚程度，我从来没听说过
York City. These club scenes were all filmed in downtown Los Angeles at the Edison nightclub. Now, the Edison nightclub is really big and they had several different rooms and they dressed them to look like two different clubs. So we only went to one location and we knocked it all out and they filled the club with all background actors. But, Ange, the Edison actually has a very cool history. The nightclub? Yes. Have you ever been there? Not only have I never been there, I've never heard of it and I've lived in LA for over 20 years now. And if that tells you my hip factor, I had never heard of
这个夜店。我也没听说过，安吉拉，我唯一去过而且至今还去过的夜店就是你带我去参加单身派对的那家。就是那样。太疯狂了。我从来没听说过那家。记得吗，那是一个朋友的朋友，他试图帮我为你策划一个夜晚。好吧，继续。嗯，爱迪生夜店在一栋历史建筑里。它叫希金斯大楼，它是洛杉矶第一个私人发电厂的所在地。怎么样？在洛杉矶市中心？是的。哇。但这是最有趣的部分，至少对我来说。他们有着装要求
this nightclub. Me either, Angela, the only nightclub I've ever been to and have still ever been to is the one you took me to for my bachelorette party. That's it. That's so crazy. And I had never heard of that one. Remember, that was like a friend of a friend who was like trying to help me plan a night out for you. Okay, go on. Well, the Edison nightclub is in a historic building. It's called the Higgins building and it was the site of LA's first private power plant. How about that? In downtown LA? Yeah. Wow. But here's the most interesting part, at least to me. They have a dress code
因为，引用一下，“我们致力于复兴旧世界的风格和曾经主导洛杉矶夜生活的浪漫感。”所以那个夜店，你必须看起来很时髦，比如你必须穿西装和裙子之类的？嗯，我想这就是他们所希望的。基本上，晚上9点以后，有些东西你是不能穿的。所以这是你不能穿的东西清单。为什么我觉得这会把我排除在外？哦，是的，因为听听你不能穿的第一样东西。运动装。哦，不。哦，我的休闲运动装。这包括短裤、球衣、连帽衫和棒球帽。所以
because, quote, we are dedicated to a resurgence of old world style and a sense of romance that once dominated Los Angeles nightlife. So the nightclub, you have to look like fancy, like you got to wear suits and dresses and what not? Well, I think that's what they're hoping for. Basically, after 9 p.m., there are certain things you cannot wear. So here's the list of things you cannot wear. Why do I feel like this is going to roll me out? Oh, yeah, because listen to the first thing you can't wear. Athletic wear. Oh, no. Oh, my athleisure wear. This includes shorts, jerseys, hoodies and baseball caps. So
乔什不能去。我不能去。你也不能背背包。哦，你不能穿人字拖、凉鞋、短袖衬衫或过度破损或宽松的牛仔裤。短袖衬衫。这很有趣。我是说，这里很热。抱歉。不知道该告诉你什么，但如果你想去我们拍摄《夜生活》的地点，你可以去，但要穿得时髦点。这就是全部了，伙计们。女士，我只有这些了。我知道我通常做三个快讯，但特里占用了我们很多时间。我想我们应该休息一下，回来后再深入探讨这一集。你是在用特里来掩盖你没有
Josh can't go. I can't go. You also can't have a backpack. Oh, you cannot wear flip flops, sandals, short sleeve shirts or excessively torn or baggy jeans. Short sleeve shirts. That's interesting. I mean, it gets hot here. Sorry. Don't know what to tell you, but if you would like to go to the location where we film night out, you can go, but dress spiffy. There you have it, folks. And lady, that's all I got. I know I normally do three fast facts, but Terry ate up a lot of our time. And I think we should just go to a break and come back and get into this episode. Are you using Terry to cover up the fact that you don't
三个快讯的事实吗？休息后见。好的。我们回来了，在进入剧集剖析之前，我必须指出一件事。是什么？我要看看你是否注意到了，听众们，你们看不到这一点，但我的女士在Zoom上看着什么东西。我不知道她是否会注意到。我正在翻阅我为这周准备的文件，没有便利贴。没有像胶带粘着的东西。是什么？我没有做任何我那些疯狂的纸条和便利贴。我把文档下载成了Word文档。是的。我输入了我的
have three fast facts? We'll see you after this break. Okey dokey. We are back and I have to point out one thing before we get into the episode breakdown. What is it? I'm gonna see if you notice listeners, you won't be able to see this, but my lady over zoom is looking at something. I don't know if she's going to notice. I'm flipping through my document that I prepared for the week and there are no sticky notes. There is nothing like taped. What is it? I did none of my crazy taping pieces of paper and sticky notes. I downloaded the document into a word document. Yes. And I typed in my
东西，而不是写在便利贴上并贴得到处都是。现代时代。安吉拉，只有纸张而没有贴上去的东西，感觉如何？我真的不知道我对此感觉如何。我真的很纠结，我会告诉你我为什么这么做。你们，这并不是我的大脑运作方式。我是个便利贴人。我把它们贴得到处都是。但问题是。你们知道我目前坐在我丈夫的衣柜里，在一张我们从男孩卧室里拖出来的小桌子上。它甚至不是一张真正的桌子。这意味着我没有台面。我没有地方
stuff instead of writing it on stickies and sticking it all over. Modern times. And how did it feel, Angela, to have just pieces of paper without things crafted to it? I really don't know how I feel about it. I'm really on the fence and I'll tell you why I did it. You guys, this isn't really how my brain works. I am a sticky note person. I stick them all over the place. But here's the thing. You guys know that I'm currently sitting in my husband's closet on a tiny table we drug in from one of the boys bedrooms. It's like not even an actual desk. That means I have no countertop. I have no place
放笔记卡和我喜欢的所有小纸片。我们在摄影棚时我喜欢那样。希望我们能回到那里。但因为台面空间的原因，它迫使我变得更精通技术，把所有东西都打进一个文档里。我也很兴奋能尽快回到摄影棚，我希望如此。但我得说，有时你有太多的笔记卡，侵占了我的空间。因为你的笔记卡，我甚至不能在桌子上放一张8.5乘11的纸。所以我很想看到某种混合形式。对你来说是一种混合形式，因为那对我来说会非常酷。但女士，做你自己。你
for note cards and all my little pieces of paper I like. I loved it when we were in the studio. Hopefully we'll be able to go back there. But because of counter space, it forced me to become more tech savvy and type it all into one document. I am also excited to soon get back into the studio, I hope. But I will say sometimes you had so many note cards that it encroached on my space. And I couldn't even fit an eight and a half by eleven sheet of paper on the desk because of your note card. So I would love to see some maybe hybrid form. A hybrid for you because that'd be super cool for me. But lady, you do you. You
每周都为播客带来精彩内容，你的方法就是你的方法。我支持它，即使这意味着我没有空间放一张纸。好吧，我必须提出来，因为如果我在这一集中表现得很烂，那是因为我没有我的便利贴。我当时想，等等，我写了什么？那在哪里？哦，天哪。是的。所以让我们从一秒钟开始。我们有一个盛开的植物接待处。又一朵花。一朵美丽的粉红色花朵。我不知道它是什么。迈克尔气喘吁吁地进来了。他衣衫不整。他的头发看起来很奇怪。是的，我们发现他在斯坦利的汽车下看到了闪亮的东西。他钻到车下试图
bring it every week to the podcast and your method is your method. And I support it even if it means I don't have room for a single sheet of paper. Well, I had to call it out because if I completely suck in this episode, it's because I don't have my stickies. And I'm like, wait, what did I write? Where's that? Oh my God. Yes. So let's kick it off at one second. We have a blooming planet reception. Another bloom. A beautiful pinkish bloom. I don't know what it is. Michael enters in a huff. He's disheveled. His hair looks weird. Yes, we find out that he saw something shiny under Stanley's car. He wiggled under the car to try and
拿到它，在这个过程中头发上沾了口香糖。是的。现在德怀特在处理这件事。我们怎么把口香糖从头发里弄出来？帕姆提到厨房里有花生酱。不过她说不是好的那种花生酱。是的，人们会生气的。不要用有机花生酱。但那是德怀特用的。他把它涂满了迈克尔的头。我是说，显然，我们是父母。我们知道你只需要把它涂在口香糖的部分。你不需要像用洗发水一样用花生酱洗头。然后他开始按摩他的头皮。我是说，德怀特把它涂满了他的头。这太荒谬了。所以我忍不住
get it and in the process got gum in his hair. Yeah. And now Dwight's on the case. How do we get the gum out of the hair? Pam mentions there's peanut butter in the kitchen. Not the good peanut butter, though, she says. Yeah, people will get mad. Don't use the organic peanut butter. But that's what Dwight uses. He slathers it all over Michael's head. I mean, obviously, we're parents. We know you just have to put it on the gum part. You don't have to like shampoo your hair with peanut butter. And then he starts massaging his scalp. I mean, Dwight puts it all over his head. It's ridiculous. So I couldn't help but
想，珍娜，他们涂在史蒂夫头上的那东西是什么？那是什么？嗯，安吉拉，你不是唯一有这个问题的人。艾米丽、基拉、莱斯利和齐亚娜也写信问他们往史蒂夫头发上涂了什么？我会告诉你们，那是真正的花生酱，但雷恩没有把它涂在史蒂夫头上。那是我们的发型师金·费里。她会把它准备好，然后雷恩走进来做最后一点润色，然后做按摩的部分。然后她必须在拍摄间隙修复它。我发现这一部分的场景只拍了几次。之后，
wonder, Jenna, what was that stuff that they put on Steve's head? What was that? Well, you're not the only person with that question, Angela. Emily, Kira, Leslie, and Ziana also wrote in asking what did they put on Steve's hair? And I will tell you, it was real peanut butter, but rain did not put it on Steve's head. It was our hairstylist, Kim Fairy. She would get it all set and then rain would step in and just do kind of like that last little touch and then do the massaging part. And then she'd have to fix it between takes. And I found out that it only took a few takes to get this part of the scene. And afterwards,
他们安排了一个史蒂夫不在的场景，这样他就可以回到发型和化妆拖车里把头发洗干净。金必须像洗头一样洗它。哦，是的。在我们的发型和化妆拖车里，你们知道，他们有传统的，你知道，在美发沙龙里那种你向后靠的洗头槽，因为它有一个小凹槽，你知道吗？是的。他们有那样的东西。所以如果你的头发需要洗，他们可以帮你洗。但水不是很热。哦，冰冷。是的。嗯，安吉拉，我得让你知道，我做了一个关于去除头发上口香糖的最佳方法的小型深度挖掘。看看你，女士。
they scheduled a scene that Steve was not in so that he could go back to the hair and makeup trailer and get his hair all washed out. Kim had to like shampoo it. Oh, yeah. In our hair and makeup trailer, you guys, they had like a traditional, you know, in a hair salon that sink you lean back in because it's got the little divot cut out, you know? Yeah. They had a thing like that. So they could wash your hair if you needed your hair washed. But the water was not very warm. Oh, it was ice cold. Yeah. Well, Angela, I'll have you know that I did a mini deep dive on the best ways to get gum out of your hair. Look at you, lady.
你真行。嗯，花生酱是去除头发上口香糖的首选推荐方案。但我发现了更多。大家听好了。你也可以用婴儿油、食用油、凡士林、粘合剂去除剂、蛋黄酱、小苏打加水、柠檬汁、白醋、冰。我想你可以把它冻住。然后它就像碎了一样。但这是我个人的最爱。而且我知道我爸爸也喜欢它。WD-40。我是说，没有什么WD-40做不到的。它能解决所有问题。你知道吗？当你提到凡士林时，我有同样的感觉。那是我们家的首选。我是说，只要涂点凡士林。你知道，如果
You go. Well, peanut butter is the number one recommended solution for gum and hair. But I did find more. Everybody listen up. You can also use baby oil, cooking oil, Vaseline, adhesive remover, mayonnaise, baking soda with water, lemon juice, white vinegar, ice. I guess you can freeze it out. And then it like breaks up. But here was my personal favorite. And I know my dad loves it too. WD 40. I mean, there's just there's nothing WD 40 can't do. It solves every problem. You know what? I felt the same way when you said Vaseline. That was our family go to. I mean, just put some Vaseline on it. You know, if
你家里只要有婴儿油、凡士林和WD-40，你几乎可以解决所有问题。是的，你准备好了。所以那是我们的开场白。现在我们要进入这一集了。迈克尔到达工作地点。我想他昨晚有个约会，因为德怀特问他进展如何。我们发现进展并不顺利。事实上，他分享说他的约会都没有进展顺利。他觉得他们都缺乏某种克劳福德特质。是的。但还有更多坏消息。嗯哼。每个人都发现他们必须在周六来上班。这次不是开玩笑。这不是迈克尔为
you just have some baby oil Vaseline and WD 40 in your house, you can solve almost every problem. Yeah, you're set. So that was our cold open. Now we're going to get into the episode. Michael arrives at work. And I guess he had a date last night because Dwight asked him how it went. We find out it did not go well. Actually, he shares that none of his dates have been going well. And he feels like they all lack a bit of a certain Crawfordness. Yeah. But there's more bad news. Mm hmm. Everyone finds out that they have to come in on Saturday. And this is not a joke this time. This is not Michael setting the
晚宴陷阱设置的舞台。这是真的。我们周六必须工作。是的，奥斯卡很愤怒。安吉拉说这太荒谬了。办公区里有很多骚动，因为他们发现周六他们必须把所有的辛勤工作，所有的销售额。他们必须把功劳归给网站。他们要把这一切都记录下来，好像是网站做的。是的，珍娜，会计部有一个场景。你知道，奥斯卡说他很愤怒。安吉拉说这太荒谬了。有一系列删除的场景。珍娜，这是帕姆和安吉拉之间的一个连续镜头。是什么？嗯，
stage for a dinner party trap. This is real. We have to work on Saturday. Yeah, Oscar is livid. Angela says it's ridiculous. There's a lot of hubbub in the bullpen because they find out on Saturday they're going to have to take all of their hard work, all of the sales they made. And they're going to have to give the credit to the website. They're going to log it all in as if the website did it. Yeah, Jenna, there's a scene in accounting. You know, Oscar saying he's livid. Angela says this is ridiculous. There is a series of deleted scenes. Jenna, it's a runner between Pam and Angela. What is it? Well,
显然，不管什么原因，这是安吉拉讨厌帕姆的日子之一。就像仅仅是你的声音。好吧，所以安吉拉和奥斯卡在谈话，帕姆把头探过隔板，对吧？她想加入谈话。这就是安吉拉说的。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？所以是肯定的。看起来是这样。该死。吉姆和我这个周末要去樱花节。抱歉。你的声音在我头上那样。抱歉。那不是很搞笑吗？就像，你在我身后的声音让我无法忍受。现在我听到了，我记得拍摄那个场景。还会有
apparently, for whatever reason, this is one of those days where Angela just hates Pam. Like just the sound of your voice. Okay, so Angela and Oscar are talking and Pam pokes her head over the partition, right? She wants to get in on the convo. And this is what Angela says. Sam, can you play the clip? So it's definite. Looks like it. Shoot. Jim and I were going to go to the Cherry Blossom Festival this weekend. I'm sorry. Your voice over my head like that. Sorry. Isn't that hilarious? Like, just your voice behind me was more than I could take. Now that I hear that, I remember shooting that. There's going to be
另一个。我要留到以后再说。所以瑞安传达了这个消息，他对此表现得超级乐观。但吉姆要在厨房里和他对质。是的。吉姆就像，嘿，伙计，你介意我跟你说件事吗？瑞安当然处于他那种超级状态。他在这一集中就是很多。他就像，太棒了。去吧。对。吉姆就像，我总觉得我们拥有的优势是我们的客户服务。无论我们怎么改变，我不知道网站是否能取代这一点。瑞安说，我看得出你对此想了很多。我很感激。谢谢。大卫·华莱士也这么认为。你在
another one. I'm going to save it for later. So Ryan has delivered this news and he's being super upbeat about it. But Jim's going to confront him in the kitchen. Yeah. Jim is like, hey, man, you mind if I run something by you? Ryan, of course, is in his like super. He's just a lot in this episode. He's like, love it. Go. Right. And Jim's like, I kind of feel like what we have going for us is our customer service. And no matter how we change this up, I don't know that a website's going to be able to replace that. Ryan goes, I can tell you thought a lot about this. I appreciate that. Thanks. David Wallace does too. You told him at
圣诞派对上告诉过他，对吧？吉姆就像，呃，瑞安就像，是啊，小心背后，吉姆。我开玩笑的。是的。我是说，瑞安对吉姆有意见。你知道，这里有个小花絮。我们本该有一集圣诞特辑，但因为编剧罢工我们没有。我知道我对此很沮丧。是的。所以这就是为什么这一季没有圣诞特辑。是的。嗯，现在我们进入会议室。迈克尔，这真的让我笑了。他试图同情瑞安为什么人们对瑞安感到不满。然后他发表了演讲。珍娜，我无法想象我的老板会这样介绍我参加会议。女士们先生们，请注意。我知道你们很多人对瑞安很生气，因为他是我们明天必须来上班的原因。然而，我向上帝发誓，如果你们中任何人以任何方式伤害他，在情感上，或者嘲讽他，或者取笑他的身高或他的半截胡子，或者我喜欢他的半截胡子。我知道如果你取笑他的半截胡子。我看到奥斯卡开始破功了。那太棒了。是的。但我非常了解奥斯卡的破功，因为我们在节目全程都坐在一起。所以当某件事让他发笑，但他试图不笑时，他会做这个小
the Christmas party, right? Jim's like, uh, and Ryan's like, yeah, watch your back, Jim. I'm just kidding. Yeah. I mean, Ryan has it out for Jim. You know, here's a bit of trivia. We would have had a Christmas episode, but we didn't because of the writer strike. I know I'm so bummed about that. Yeah. So that's why this season does not have a Christmas episode. Yeah. Well, now we move into the conference room. And Michael, this really made me laugh. He's sort of trying to sympathize with Ryan why people are feeling resentful towards Ryan. And then he makes this speech. And Jenna, I could not imagine being introduced by my boss for a meeting like
动作，他的头会微微点一下。这太细微了，你们。太细微了。但当迈克尔说到胡子那部分时，奥斯卡做了那个点头动作。我当时想，哦，奥斯卡，我看到你了。在他可爱的介绍之后，瑞安开始非常热情地捍卫“邓德·米夫林2.0”。是的。他滔滔不绝。他知道网站被黑了。他试图捍卫它。珍娜，在他演讲时我有个会议桌的发现。什么？4分30秒。会议桌上有两个咖啡杯。有什么猜测吗？是谁的？嗯，其中一个是帕姆的粉色杯子，因为我看到了。我
this. Ladies and gentlemen, may I have your attention, please? I know that a lot of you are very angry with Ryan because he is the reason we all have to come in tomorrow. However, I swear to God, if any of you hurts him in any way, emotionally, or taunts him, or makes fun of his height or his half beard, or I love his half beard. I know if you make fun of his half beard. I saw Oscar start to break. That's huge. Yes. But I know Oscars tells so well because we sat next to each other for the whole run of the show. So one of the things he does when something makes him laugh, but he's trying not to laugh, is he does this little
没有注意到另一个，因为我在看大型集体场景时只看我自己。但我确实看到我有我的杯子。吉姆也有。哦，没有其他人有咖啡杯。只有吉姆和帕姆。我开始想，除了派对，你什么时候见过有人在会议室里拿饮料？一直都有。我总是把杯子带进会议室，安吉拉，因为我可以在场景中喝咖啡。这对我来说是一件大事。所以你知道吗？你可能没穿连裤袜，但你也没想到带饮料进房间。哦，天哪。嗯，我想我确实有
thing with his head where he kind of nods his head down. And it's so slight, you guys. It's so slight. But when Michael says the part about the beard, Oscar does that little head nod thing. And I was like, oh, Oscar, I see you. After his lovely introduction, Ryan starts defending Dunder Mifflin 2.0. Very passionately. Yeah. And he's going on and on. He knows the website was hacked. He's trying to defend it. Jenna, I have a conference table catch during his speech. What? Four minutes, 30 seconds. There are two coffee mugs on the conference table. Any guesses? Who's they are? Well, one of them is Pam's pink mug because I saw it. I
帕姆拿着杯子的记忆，但我不敢相信。他们都有杯子。我很嫉妒。哦，约翰和我都在想我们怎么能在工作时喝咖啡。所以是的，别担心。你现在会经常看到这一点。一旦你发现了一次，它就会成为你永远无法忽视的东西。好了，伙计们，我们有新东西要追踪了。谁在会议室场景里喝咖啡？嗯，我在这个会议室场景中最喜欢的时刻之一，安吉拉，是敏迪的台词。当她说，我有很多问题。第一，你怎么敢？我太喜欢了。我们收到了乔斯林·苏米的粉丝提问，她说，
did not notice another one because I only look at myself when I'm watching big group scenes. But I did see that I had my mug. So does Jim. Oh, no one else has a coffee mug. Just Jim and Pam. And I started thinking, when did you ever see anyone with a beverage in the conference room except a party? All the time. I always brought my mug into the conference room, Angela, because I could actually drink coffee during the scene. It was a big thing for me. So you know what? You maybe didn't wear your pantyhose, but you also didn't think to bring a beverage into the room. Oh my gosh. Well, I guess I kind of have
这是我家人引用最多的台词。所以我必须知道是谁写的。请告诉我那是敏迪·卡灵。是的，敏迪写了这句台词。她在接受《办公室电视》采访时被问到了这句台词。我喜欢她的回答。哦，让我们听听。这是她说的，引用一下，“我从不故意给自己最有趣的台词。然而，由于我作为喜剧演员的天赋，它们往往被认为是最有趣的。有时我试图给自己一些非常沉闷、不好笑的台词，以免抢走焦点。但即使那样也不起作用，因为它们在交付时总是闪闪发光。这很难。作为如此
memories of Pam holding her mug, but I couldn't believe it. They both had mugs. I was jealous. Oh, John and I were all over the how can we drink coffee at work. So yeah, don't worry. You're going to see that a lot now. Now that you've spotted it once, it's going to be something you can never unsee. All right, guys, we have something new to track. Who's drinking coffee in conference room scenes? Well, one of my favorite moments in this conference room scene, Angela, is Mindy's line. When she says, I have a lot of questions. Number one, how dare you? I loved it so much. We got a fan question from Jocelyn Sumi, who said,
美妙的人，这很难。但我只是喜欢那样。我觉得这真的很有趣。那真的很有趣。我20多岁住在纽约时有个朋友。每当她喝点小酒，不可避免地她会说，你怎么敢？就像我们会说，嘿，听着，我们得走了。上出租车吧。上出租车。你知道吗？你怎么敢？就像，好吧，你喝够了。那是她的破功。是的，那是她的破功。你怎么敢？什么？我只是让你拿你的钱包。你怎么敢？好吧，好吧。我必须说我最喜欢的另一个部分。这个场景是迈克尔的慢拍手。他带头慢拍手作为
this is the line that is most quoted by my family. So I have to know who wrote it. Please tell me it was Mindy Kaling. Yes, Mindy wrote this line. And she was asked about this line in an interview she did with office telly. And I loved her answer. Oh, let's hear it. Here's what she said, quote, I never intentionally give myself the funniest lines. However, they often resonate as the funniest because of my gifts as a comic actor. Sometimes I try to give myself really drab, unfunny lines so as to not steal focus. But even that doesn't work because they always sparkle upon delivery. It's hard. It's hard being so
捍卫瑞安的一种方式。我确实喜欢它。我认为这是迈克尔的一个非常大胆的选择。那就像一个标志性的电影时刻。所以你知道，我必须对电影中的慢拍手做一个小型挖掘，因为它们总是很棒。它们从来没有，永远不会停止变得很棒。当我在IMDb上查找有多少电影有慢拍手时。有大约一百部。有太多电影了。珍娜，体育电影有慢拍手。像，法律剧情电影有慢拍手。委员会电影有讽刺的慢拍手。每个类型都有慢拍手。我非常清楚地记得我第一次接触慢拍手。我记得
fabulous, y'all. But I just loved that. I thought it was really funny. That is really funny. I had a friend when I lived in New York in my 20s. And whenever she'd get a little tipsy, inevitably she'd say, how dare you? Like we'd be like, Hey, listen, we got to go. Let's get in the cab. Get in the cab. You know what? How dare you? Like, okay, you had enough. That was her tell. Yeah, that was her tell. How dare you? What? I just asked you to grab your purse. How dare you? Okay, okay. I have to say another one of my favorite parts. This scene is the slow clap by Michael. He leads a slow clap as a way of
我看的第一部有慢拍手的电影。哦，女士，我们都知道我们第一次看到慢拍手的电影。我是说，你的是什么？《买不到的爱》，帕特里克·德姆西主演。是的，绝对。桌子外面的著名慢拍手。嗯哼。是的。哦，是的。所以首先，我以为慢拍手是80年代、90年代的电影元素，因为我记得它来自像《卢卡斯》、《冰上轻舞》、《军官与绅士》、《闻香识女人》、《鲁迪》这样的电影。等等，等等，等等，等等，我必须阻止你。《军官与绅士》和《闻香识女人》里有慢拍手？是的。哦，《闻香识女人》。它发生在法庭上。
defending Ryan. And I do love it. I thought it was a very bold choice by Michael. That's like an iconic movie moment. So you know, I had to do a mini dive on the slow clap in movies because they are always amazing. They never, ever cease to not be amazing. When I went on IMDb and looked up how many movies had a slow clap. There's like a hundred. There's like so many movies. Jenna, sports movies have slow claps. Like, law dramatic movies have slow claps. Committees have sarcastic slow claps. There are slow claps in every genre. I remember very clearly my introduction to the slow clap. I remember
不，《军官与绅士》。它发生在工厂里。是的。抱歉，因为它让我震惊，因为我真的只把慢拍手与80年代青少年电影联系在一起。这就是我为什么抓狂的原因。它们在剧情片里。它们无处不在，女士，特别是在体育电影里。好吧，《鲁迪》、《印第安纳州人》、《书呆子的复仇》、《早餐俱乐部》、《买不到的爱》，正如你所说，《不是另一部青少年电影》、《校园蓝调》。准备好这个。 《泽西女孩》。哇。《泽西女孩》，本·阿弗莱克主演。总之，名单还在继续，你们。我真的以为这一切始于80年代和90年代，但根据
the first movie that I watched with a slow clap. Oh, lady, we all know the first movie we saw a slow clap in. I mean, what was yours? Can't Buy Me Love with Patrick Dempsey. Yes, absolutely. Famous slow clap at the tables outside. Mm hmm. Yeah. Oh yeah. So first of all, I thought the slow clap was like an 80s, 90s movie thing because I remembered it from movies like Lucas, Cool Runnings, Officer and a Gentleman, Scent of a Woman, Rudy. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I have to stop you. There's a slow clap in Officer and a Gentleman and Scent of a Woman. Yes. Oh, Scent of a Woman. It happens in the courtroom.
互联网，我错了。第一次慢拍手是在1968年的一部电影中，叫《冬狮》，彼得·奥图尔饰演亨利二世。他在凯瑟琳·赫本饰演的阿基坦的埃莉诺发表戏剧性恳求后，向她慢拍手。哇。我知道。我觉得慢拍手有子类别。真诚的、讽刺的、欢乐的、召集部队的。是的，鼓舞人心的慢拍手。愤怒的、自以为是的慢拍手。谢谢你做那个。不客气。嗯，我觉得这很迷人，安吉拉。继续。我不知道你是否想追踪这个，留恋的拥抱。哦，因为那就像慢拍手一样，是一回事。迈克尔
No, Officer and a Gentleman. It happens in the factory. Yes. I'm sorry, because it's shocking me because I really only associate the slow clap with 80s teen movies. That's why I was freaking out. They're in dramas. They're everywhere, lady, especially in sports movies. Okay, Rudy, Hoosiers, Revenge of the Nerds, The Breakfast Club, Can't Buy Me Love as you said, not another teen movie, Varsity Blues. Get ready for this one. Jersey Girl. Wow. Jersey Girl with Ben Affleck. Anyway, the list goes on and on, you guys. And I really thought it all started in the 80s and 90s, but according to the
在告别时要对瑞安使用留恋的拥抱。他只是要说，伙计，你认识什么女人可以介绍给我吗，在纽约？瑞安说，我不认识什么特别的人，但纽约俱乐部的女人太棒了。这会给迈克尔想法。你不能对迈克尔说那样的话。不，他决定问吉姆是否想去泡吧。嗯，我应该说他通过问吉姆是否会和梅雷迪思发生性关系以及他是否认为梅雷迪思能谨慎行事来引导那段对话。但那导致了，你想和我一起去纽约泡吧吗？因为他们都是单身，对吧？吉姆说，我在和帕姆约会。迈克尔说，哦，那还在继续吗？什么？所以当然，现在迈克尔必须拉上德怀特，安迪也想去。他说老球和链子最近链子比球多。你知道我的意思吗？我不知道那是什么意思，但让我觉得恶心。安吉拉说，我就在这里。珍娜。是的。我想把这个时刻称为“你好，超级伪君子”。6分52秒。我站在前台，你可以清楚地看到我的孕妇装从毛衣下面露出来。我看到了。而且有一个
internet, I was wrong. The very first slow clap was in 1968 in a movie called The Lion in Winter, starring Peter O'Toole as Henry II. He slow claps to Catherine Hepburn as Eleanor of Aquitaine after her dramatic plea. Wow. I know. I feel like there are subcategories of slow claps. Ernest, sarcastic, joyous, rally the troops. Yes, inspirational slow clap. Angry, smart ass slow clap. Thank you for doing that. You're welcome. Well, I found that fascinating, Angela. Moving on. I don't know if you want to track this, the lingering hug. Oh, because that's like the slow clap, a thing. Michael is
整个NG镜头发生在这里，我从复印机后面笑着走出来，抓着，挠着我巨大的肚子。嗯，这一切为迈克尔和德怀特在纽约的城镇里大闹一场奠定了基础。他们从瑞安的助理那里得知他会在一个叫“特权”的俱乐部。这是瑞安见到迈克尔或德怀特时最开心的一次。这真是一句有趣的台词，因为他见到他们太兴奋了，以至于迈克尔说，瑞安，我是迈克尔和德怀特。他就像，我想也许你没看清我。是的。他就像，我知道你们，迈克尔
going to employ a lingering hug with Ryan as he says goodbye. And he's just going to say like, dude, do you know any women you could set me up with in New York? And Ryan says, I don't know anyone specifically, but the women in the clubs in New York are amazing. This is going to give Michael ideas. You can't say something like that to Michael. No, he decides to ask Jim if he'd like to go clubbing. Well, I should say he leads that conversation by asking Jim if he would ever have sex with Meredith and if he thinks Meredith can be discreet. But then that leads to, do you want to go clubbing with me in
就像，好吧。珍娜，在8分24秒。如果你喜欢在背景中发现一些有趣的东西，有一个穿蓝色纽扣衬衫的家伙在进行精彩的背景舞蹈。他正在享受他一生中最美好的时光。我喜欢它。这也是瑞安要向我们介绍他的朋友特洛伊的时候，德怀特说，你看起来像个霍比特人。他实际上已经有点痴迷于特洛伊可能真的来自《指环王》世界的想法。这就是德怀特疯狂的地方。他一次又一次地在节目中这样做，他实际上相信这些奇幻类型中的一些。你知道，就像
New York? Because they're both single, right? And Jim's like, I'm dating bam. And Michael says, Oh, that's still going on. What? So of course, now Michael has to enlist Dwight and Andy wants to go. He says the old ball and chain has been more chain than ball lately. You know what I mean? I don't know what that means, but gross me out. And Angela says, I'm right here. Jenna. Yep. I would like to call this moment. Hello, super prigs. Six minutes, 52 seconds. I'm standing at front reception and you can clearly see my maternity shirt hanging out from under my sweater. I saw it. And there's a
这对我来说很疯狂，但他很真诚。他真的相信他可能是个霍比特人并拥有特殊力量。是的。当然，任何拥有特殊力量的人对德怀特来说都非常感兴趣。是的。安吉拉，迈克尔无法理解瓶装服务女服务员做什么，这让我很着迷。这让我想起了你和我，当我们确实去过一次夜店，体验过我们一生中唯一一次瓶装服务时。真是个笑话。好吧。就像每个人都说，哦，瓶装服务。珍娜和我当时想，好吧，我们从来没做过这个。大约200美元还是什么的。我只记得我们拿到账单时，我们想，什么？他们点亮了这个像
whole blooper that happens right here where I come around from the copier laughing, itching, scratching my enormous belly. Well, this all sets the stage for what is going to become Michael and Dwight hitting the town in New York. They found out from Ryan's assistant that he would be at a club called prerogative. It's the happiest Ryan has ever been to see Michael or Dwight. It's such a funny line because he's so excited to see them that Michael says, Ryan, it's Michael and Dwight. He's like, I think maybe you haven't seen me clearly. Yeah. He's like, I know what you guys and Michael's
烟花一样的东西。他们有烟花，他们走过来，带着一个大托盘，上面有各种各样的伏特加或什么的，还有调酒器。珍娜和我都不喝那些东西。所以就像，有什么意义？我本希望有零食什么的。不，就像迈克尔同样的问题。没有零食。只有一托盘酒瓶和调酒器。然后就是这样。安吉拉，要200美元，但你还得自己调酒。那有什么意义？我只是想要调酒师调的一杯大都会。但现在我得试着自己调酒。我几乎不知道我在做什么。我非常像迈克尔·斯科特。我会这么说。我本来会喜欢的
like, okay. Jenna, at eight minutes, 24 seconds. If you love to spot some fun stuff in the background, there's some fantastic background dancing by a guy and a blue button down. He's having the time of his life. I love it. This is also when Ryan is going to introduce us to his friend Troy and Dwight says, you look like a hobbit. He's actually become sort of obsessed with the idea that Troy might actually be from the world of the Lord of the Rings. This is the crazy thing about Dwight. And he does this again and again throughout the show where he actually believes in some of this fantastical genre. You know, like
好吧，珍娜，在8分24秒的时候。如果你喜欢在背景中寻找一些有趣的东西，有一个穿着蓝色扣领衬衫的家伙在背景里跳舞，跳得太棒了。他玩得非常开心。我喜欢这个。这也是瑞安向我们介绍他的朋友特洛伊的时候，德怀特说，你看起来像个霍比特人。他实际上已经有点沉迷于特洛伊可能真的来自《指环王》世界的想法了。这就是德怀特疯狂的地方。他在整个节目中一次又一次地这样做，他真的相信一些这种奇幻类型的东西。你知道，就像
it's crazy to me, but he's earnest. He really believes he might be a hobbit and have special powers. Yes. And of course, anyone with special powers is of great interest to Dwight. Yeah. I was really charmed, Angela, by Michael's inability to understand what a bottle service waitress does. This reminded me of you and I when we did go to One Night Club and experienced bottle service one time in our lives. What a joke. Okay. Like everyone was like, oh, bottle service. And Jenna and I were like, okay, we'd never done this. It's like $200 or something. I just remember we got the bill and we're like, what? And they light up this little like
这对我来说太疯狂了，但他很认真。他真的相信他可能是个霍比特人，拥有特殊能力。是的。当然，任何拥有特殊能力的人都会引起德怀特的极大兴趣。是的。安吉拉，迈克尔无法理解瓶装服务女服务员是做什么的，这真的很吸引我。这让我想起了你和我，我们有一次去夜店体验过一次瓶装服务。真是个笑话。好吧，每个人都说，哦，瓶装服务。我和珍娜当时想，好吧，我们从来没做过这个。大概要200美元左右。我只记得我们拿到账单时，我们想，什么？然后他们点亮了这个小小的像
sparklers. They have sparklers and they walk over with a big tray of all of this different type of vodka or something and mixers. Jenna and I don't drink any of that stuff. So it was like, what's the point? I was hoping there'd be snacks or something. No, like Michael's same problem. There's no snacks. It's just a tray of liquor bottles and mixers. And then here's the thing. Angela, it's $200, but then you have to make your own drinks. What's the point of that? I just wanted a cosmopolitan from the bartender. But now I'm trying to make my own drink. I barely know what I'm doing. I was very Michael Scott. I'll say that. I would have loved
烟花。他们拿着烟花，端着一大盘各种各样的伏特加或类似的东西和调酒饮料走过来。我和珍娜根本不喝那些东西。所以这有什么意义呢？我当时还希望会有零食之类的。不，就像迈克尔遇到的同样的问题。没有零食。只有一盘酒瓶和调酒饮料。还有，最关键的是，安吉拉，要200美元，但你还得自己调酒。那有什么意义呢？我只是想从调酒师那里点一杯大都会鸡尾酒。但现在我得试着自己调酒。我根本不知道自己在做什么。我当时真的很像迈克尔·斯科特。我得说，我本来会很喜欢的
a glass of Maraschino cherries just to eat them. I was so hungry. I would have loved some chicken fingers and a glass of wine, but now we have sparklers for $200. I don't know if you guys noticed, but Michael wanted to order a Midori sour, which I thought was an amazing callback to the convention season three. Yeah. Remember when Jim and Josh had that inside joke, a shot of Midori perhaps. I still think Michael thinks that's a drink that you order when you want to be fancy because of Jim and Josh. This is a way Michael and I are similar. I would also grab on to a story like that and be like, okay, wait, so when I'm in the club
一罐马拉斯奇诺樱桃，就为了吃它们。我太饿了。我本来很想吃点鸡柳，喝杯红酒，但现在我们却花了200美元买了仙女棒。不知道你们有没有注意到，迈克尔想点一杯翠绿酸酒，我觉得这真是对第三季会议情节的绝妙呼应。是的。还记得吉姆和乔什那个内部笑话吗，也许是一杯翠绿酸酒。我依然觉得迈克尔认为那是你想装腔作势时会点的酒，因为吉姆和乔什喝过。这就是迈克尔和我相似的地方。我也会抓住这样的故事不放，心想，好吧，等等，所以当我在夜店时
to be cool, order Midori sour. Got it. And chicken fingers. But there's no chicken fingers. You're just going to get a cup of olives. So meanwhile, back in the office, Jim has some ideas. He's a real idea man, even after the whole birthday thing blew up in his face. His big idea is that if everyone stays late for just a few hours, then they won't have to come in tomorrow. Jim, I hope you were thorough when you decided to suggest this and that you crossed all your T's and dotted your eyes because I'm sure people are still pissed off at you about the cakes. I have some news for you, Angela. He did not do any of that. It turns out that everyone
为了显得酷，就点翠绿酸酒。明白了。还有鸡柳。但这里没有鸡柳。你只能得到一杯橄榄。与此同时，回到办公室，吉姆有一些想法。他真是个点子大王，即使在整个生日事件搞砸之后。他的大点子是，如果每个人都多留几个小时，那么明天就不用来上班了。吉姆，我希望你在提出这个建议时考虑周全，把所有细节都落实到位，因为我敢肯定大家还在因为蛋糕的事生你的气。安吉拉，我有个消息要告诉你。他根本没做这些。结果每个人
stayed late and then at 9 p.m. when they decide to leave, they discover that they are locked into the parking lot. Yes, lady. There is a fantastic group shot at 8 minutes 48 seconds where it pans everyone as they realize they're locked in. And I just want you to know at this point I have reached the point in my pregnancy where I can no longer button up my coat and my purse is no longer really hiding my belly. I have more news for you. Not only is the parking gate locked such that they cannot leave, they also cannot return to the comfort of the office because Pam has locked the door from the inside and she doesn't have a
都留到了很晚，然后在晚上9点决定离开时，他们发现自己被锁在停车场里了。是的，女士。在8分48秒处有一个精彩的集体镜头，镜头扫过每个人，他们意识到自己被锁在里面了。我只想让你们知道，此时我已经怀孕到了无法扣上外套扣子的阶段，我的包也再也遮不住我的肚子了。我还有更多消息要告诉你。不仅停车场大门锁住了，他们无法离开，他们也无法回到舒适的办公室，因为帕姆从里面锁上了门，而且她没有
key. Mm-hmm. Pam has a talking head that is so great. She said that Dwight has both the master and spare key and when she asked him how they'd get into the office if he ever died, he responded with, Jenna, you say it. If I'm dead, you guys have been dead for weeks. Yeah. Okay, Dwight. Okay. Yeah. One of my favorite lines in all of this is Stanley when he declares that if he is not in his bath with a glass of wine within the hour, they're both dead. Now, Jenna, that line to me was the closest to Leslie David Baker in real life than any other line he ever said on the show because he and I would talk about how we couldn't wait
钥匙。嗯哼。帕姆有一个非常棒的采访镜头。她说德怀特既有主钥匙也有备用钥匙，当她问他如果他死了他们该怎么进办公室时，他回答说，珍娜，你来说。如果我死了，你们早就死好几周了。是的。好吧，德怀特。好吧。是的。我最喜欢的台词之一是斯坦利说的，如果他不能在一小时内泡在浴缸里喝上一杯红酒，他们就都死定了。现在，珍娜，那句台词对我来说，比他在剧中说的任何其他台词都更接近现实生活中的莱斯利·大卫·贝克，因为我和他经常谈论我们有多么迫不及待
to get home and take a bath with a glass of wine with a glass of wine, you know, like soak our muscles. Yes, I thought the same thing, Angela. Well, they get an idea. It's very simple. All we have to do is call the security guard and ask him to come unlock the gate. Yeah. But no one has his phone number and no one can remember his name. Yeah. No one can remember his name, but Toby has his phone number. He has his phone number, but he did not enter his name with the phone number into his phone. So we still have the name dilemma, but Toby does save the day and Pam is very impressed. And it's probably Toby's happiest moment in his
回家泡个澡，喝杯红酒，你知道，就像放松一下肌肉。是的，我也这么想，安吉拉。好吧，他们想到了一个主意。很简单。我们只需要给保安打电话，让他来开门。是的。但没人有他的电话号码，也没人记得他的名字。是的。没人记得他的名字，但托比有他的电话号码。他有他的电话号码，但他没把名字存进手机里。所以我们仍然面临名字的困境，但托比确实拯救了大家，帕姆印象非常深刻。这可能是托比一生中最快乐的时刻。
whole entire life. Yes. It's gonna lead him to make a mistake later, but we'll get there. Some really big swings are about to come from Toby. We had a fan catch from Ben M. and Skyler T. Can we talk about how Creed is the person who knows Hank's name when nobody else seems to know it? He seems like the least likely person who would know anyone's name as it has been established. I just loved that. I loved it and I thought it was actually perfect. I feel like Creed would know Hank's name. I feel like Creed sort of has a person on the inside wherever he is. I mean, how many times has Hank probably had to let Creed in or
是的。这会导致他后来犯错，但我们稍后再说。托比即将做出一些非常大的举动。我们收到了本·M和斯凯勒·T的粉丝反馈。我们能谈谈为什么克里德是唯一知道汉克名字的人，而其他人似乎都不知道吗？他看起来是最不可能知道别人名字的人，正如之前所确定的那样。我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢它，我觉得这实际上很完美。我觉得克里德会知道汉克的名字。我觉得克里德无论在哪里都有内线。我是说，汉克可能有多少次不得不让克里德进出
out of the building? We know he slept there many nights. That's right. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, Dwight is really wowing Ryan and Troy about Weevil season details. That is a great go-to-break description. Well, we're back. Dwight is holding court talking about Weevil season. Ryan is kind of jittery. Says he's got to go to the bathroom again. Dwight is positive he might have a UTI. Yeah, he says I'll order you some cranberry juice for his urinary tract infection. Well, this made me wonder. Oh no, about UTIs or cranberry juice. Both. Okay. Because this is a thing that women are told will help
大楼？我们知道他在那儿睡过很多晚。没错。好吧，我们休息一下。回来后，德怀特真的让瑞安和特洛伊对象鼻虫季节的细节感到惊叹。那是一个很棒的休息前描述。好吧，我们回来了。德怀特正在侃侃而谈象鼻虫季节。瑞安有点紧张。说他又要去洗手间了。德怀特肯定他可能得了尿路感染。是的，他说我会为你点些蔓越莓汁来治疗他的尿路感染。好吧，这让我很好奇。哦不，是关于尿路感染还是蔓越莓汁。两者都是。好吧。因为这是女性被告知有助于
their UTIs. Cranberry juice. I thought it's time to deep dive it. Oh, well, let's hear it. Maybe we'll help people today, Jenna. Perhaps. Perhaps after listening to this podcast, you will not only know when to get a rabies vaccine, but you will also know what to do when you get a UTI. We'll see. Here's the question. Does cranberry juice prevent or cure a UTI? One group of researchers tested cranberry juice cocktail, as this is very easy to find. But wait, are there any real cranberries in the cranberry juice cocktail? Yes, there is some. There's also a lot of sugar. However, the researchers discovered that in Petri dishes, the
治疗尿路感染的方法。蔓越莓汁。我想是时候深入研究一下了。哦，好吧，让我们听听。也许我们今天能帮到大家，珍娜。也许吧。也许听完这期播客，你不仅会知道什么时候该打狂犬疫苗，还会知道得了尿路感染该怎么办。我们走着瞧。问题是这样的。蔓越莓汁能预防或治愈尿路感染吗？一组研究人员测试了蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒，因为这很容易买到。但等等，蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒里真的有蔓越莓吗？是的，有一些。里面也有很多糖。然而，研究人员发现，在培养皿中，
cranberry metabolites did prevent E. coli from sticking to other bacteria, therefore limiting its ability to grow and multiply. Huh. In Petri dishes, cranberry juice cocktail did this. But does that translate to the human body? Unsure. What about the super cadupre cranberry juice that's like all organic? You know the kind you see at the grocery store that has like sediment at the bottom because it's like super healthy just cranberry-ness. I wondered the same thing. I could not find a study on that, but I did find a study where they tested cranberry capsules, which would be that same kind of highly concentrated
蔓越莓代谢物确实阻止了大肠杆菌粘附在其他细菌上，从而限制了它的生长和繁殖能力。嗯。在培养皿中，蔓越莓汁鸡尾酒确实做到了这一点。但这能转化为人体内的效果吗？不确定。那那种超级纯的蔓越莓汁呢，就是全有机的？你知道你在杂货店看到的那种，底部有沉淀物，因为它超级健康，全是蔓越莓精华。我也想过同样的问题。我没找到关于那个的研究，但我确实找到了一项研究，他们测试了蔓越莓胶囊，那应该就是那种高度浓缩的
cranberry business. Yeah, yeah. They tested 185 female nursing home residents. They gave them cranberry pills for one year, and they found that there was no statistical significant difference in the presence of bacteria between the people who took the pills and the control group. So at the end of the day, most studies suggest that juice and supplements do not have enough of the active ingredient, which is called A-type proanthocidioninsins. You heard it. I said it right. Prophesicinininins. Uh-huh. That's right. To prevent bacteria from sticking to the urinary tract, and therefore, if you think you have an
蔓越莓产品。是的，是的。他们测试了185名疗养院的女性居民。他们给她们服用蔓越莓药丸一年，发现服用药丸的人和对照组之间在细菌存在方面没有统计学上的显著差异。所以归根结底，大多数研究表明，果汁和补充剂没有足够的活性成分，也就是A型原花青素。你听到了。我说对了。原花青素。嗯哼。没错。无法阻止细菌粘附在尿道上，因此，如果你认为自己得了
infection, call your doctor, get some antibiotics, and to prevent a UTI, the best things you can do are ladies, wipe front to back, always front to back, pee after sex, and take regular probiotics. I think that's a very solid deep dive on cranberries and UTIs. I hope the listeners of this podcast will experience fewer UTIs and or get their UTI problems solved more quickly after listening to today's episode. Where do we go from there? Well, well, I guess we could go back to the lobby of Dunder Mifflin because guess what? Jim got a hold of Hank. Woo-hoo! Hank is gonna be there in under an hour. Oscar says, man,
感染，请去看医生，服用抗生素，而要预防尿路感染，女士们，最好的做法是：从前往后擦，一定要从前往后，性交后排尿，并定期服用益生菌。我认为这是对蔓越莓和尿路感染非常扎实的深入研究。我希望听众们在听完今天的节目后，能减少尿路感染，或者更快地解决尿路感染问题。接下来我们去哪儿？好吧，好吧，我想我们可以回到邓德·米福林的大厅，因为你猜怎么着？吉姆联系上汉克了。呜呼！汉克不到一小时就会到。奥斯卡说，伙计，
we have to make sure we give him a big tip this Christmas. And that's when they realized that no one tipped him last Christmas because Jim was supposed to collect the money from everyone. Well, Jim is really on a roll here. Way to go, Jim. Way to go, Jim. You're just ticking everyone off left and right. There are a series of fantastic deleted scenes that all happened in the lobby. There was a much bigger story here, but I think they just ran out of time in the episode. So you guys, there's a second one of Angela just being annoyed at Pam. Sam, can we hear that? You did it. But I have to walk my cats. I'm sure they'll be okay for one
这个圣诞节我们一定要给他一大笔小费。就在那时他们意识到去年圣诞节没人给他小费，因为吉姆本该负责向大家收钱的。好吧，吉姆这次真是搞砸了。干得好，吉姆。干得好，吉姆。你真是把每个人都得罪光了。有一系列精彩的删减片段都发生在大厅里。这里本来有一个更大的故事，但我认为他们只是在这一集中没时间了。所以你们这些家伙，还有第二个片段是安吉拉对帕姆感到恼火。萨姆，我们能听听那个吗？你做到了。但我得遛我的猫。我相信它们待一
night. Stop taking his side. We're not all sleeping with Jim. That's not a nice thing to say. You know what's not nice? Unexercised cats. You know what else is not nice? Coming home and looking into your cat's eyes and seeing nothing but disappointment. That's a bit much, isn't it? I mean, listen to the two of them with their digs back and forth. How about Andy asking everyone to raise their hand and vote on who is the best couple, Pam, Jim, or Andy and Angela? And then you all vote for yourselves, by the way I noticed. Oh, and Phyllis votes for us too. So how about them apples? Well, there are two more deleted scenes from us all being
晚没问题的。别再站在他那边了。我们又不是都和吉姆睡过。那话可不好听。你知道什么不好听吗？没运动的猫。你还知道什么不好听吗？回家看着你猫的眼睛，看到的只有失望。这有点过分了，不是吗？我是说，听听他们俩互相挖苦。安迪让大家举手表决谁是最好的情侣，帕姆和吉姆，还是安迪和安吉拉？顺便说一句，我注意到你们都投了自己一票。哦，菲利斯也投了我们。那又怎么样呢？好吧，还有两个删减片段是关于我们都被
stuck in the lobby and parking lot that I loved. One, and Jenna, I remember you guys filming this. I don't know if you remember it. One is where Phyllis, Pam, Oscar, and Toby are all huddled up watching a movie on an iPod, and it's about the Bolin sisters. I do remember that now that you say it. You're holding up like the little headphones each so you can kind of hear. Yes. And you're watching it on an iPod. Do you know how small those screens were? I do remember. Very tiny. Like about the size of a large postage stamp. Yeah, exactly. And another scene that I loved is that Stanley's wife brings him snacks to the
困在大厅和停车场里的，我很喜欢。一个，珍娜，我记得你们拍了这个。不知道你还记不记得。一个是菲利斯、帕姆、奥斯卡和托比都挤在一起用iPod看电影，是关于博林姐妹的。你这么一说我确实记得了。你们每个人都举着小耳机，这样就能听到了。是的。而且你们是在iPod上看的。你知道那些屏幕有多小吗？我记得。非常小。大概只有一张大邮票那么大。是的，完全正确。我喜欢的另一个场景是斯坦利的妻子给他送零食到
fence. Oh yeah. And Stanley drinks like a milkshake or something through the mesh fence using a straw, and it's such a cute scene. A lady, should we go back to the club? Oh, it is not going well in the club. Michael has just talked to a young gal who had never even heard of Back to the Future. So Ryan is like, should we go to a club where there's older girls? And Michael's like, yeah. You know, Angela, this got me thinking. This whole club thing. Michael's gonna relocate to another club to meet a woman. Why isn't Michael doing online dating? Right? They didn't have online dating then. Oh, yes, they did. I looked it up. Oh, you were
栅栏那儿。哦，是的。斯坦利隔着铁丝网用吸管喝奶昔之类的东西，那真是一个可爱的场景。女士，我们要回到夜店吗？哦，夜店里的情况不太妙。迈克尔刚和一个从未听说过《回到未来》的年轻女孩聊过。所以瑞安说，我们要不要去一个有大龄女孩的夜店？迈克尔说，好啊。你知道吗，安吉拉，这让我开始思考。整个夜店这件事。迈克尔要换个夜店去见女人。为什么迈克尔不尝试在线约会呢？对吧？那时他们还没有在线约会。哦，有的，有的。我查过了。哦，你是在
setting me up. What? Seriously? Well, first of all, in an earlier episode, we saw Michael setting up an online dating profile that we never see him use. But I googled it. The very first online dating site was called Kiss.com, and it launched in 1994. But it was followed the very next year by Match.com, which sort of took over the whole online dating world. But that was 1995. By this time, Michael would have several options. Ashley Madison came on the scene in 2002. Okay, Cupid was 2004. Anyway, I'm just saying he had options that weren't driving to New York and going to weird nightclubs with Ryan. Oh, I know all
给我下套。什么？认真的吗？好吧，首先，在之前的一集中，我们看到迈克尔建立了一个在线约会资料，但我们从没见他用过。但我谷歌了一下。第一个在线约会网站叫Kiss.com，成立于1994年。但紧接着第二年就出现了Match.com，它几乎接管了整个在线约会世界。但那是1995年。到这个时候，迈克尔会有很多选择。阿什利·麦迪逊在2002年出现。OKCupid是2004年。总之，我只是说他有很多选择，而不是开车去纽约，和瑞安去奇怪的夜店。哦，我全
about the dating sites and the apps because Jenna, I went viral because my nephew who was new to Tinder, his friends were like, you need to have a hook so the gals don't swipe right or left. I don't know, Tinder, whatever, they swipe or something, right? So my nephew found a like family photo that I was in and he was like, yeah, that's me and my aunt from the office. And it went viral, right? Because all of a sudden my face is on Tinder. And I had to call my nephews. I have more than one. And I said, Hey, guys, I'm just going to blanket statement here to all of you. Don't use a photo of me to help you get laid. Thank you. He
都知道那些约会网站和应用程序，因为珍娜，我火了，因为我侄子刚接触Tinder，他的朋友们说，你需要一个钩子，这样女孩们就不会向右或向左滑。我不知道，Tinder，随便什么，她们会滑之类的，对吧？所以我侄子找到了我的一张家庭合影，他说，是的，那是我和我来自《办公室》的阿姨。然后就火了，对吧？因为突然间我的脸出现在了Tinder上。我不得不给我的侄子们打电话。我不止一个侄子。我说，嘿，伙计们，我在这里对你们所有人做一个统一声明。别用我的照片来帮你们约炮。谢谢。他
was horrified and super embarrassed. He took the photo down immediately, said that he was really embarrassed. His friends talked him into that hook. But guess what? There's a lovely button wrap up button to the story. Years later, he in fact met a gal using a fabulous photo just of himself. And they started dating, they got engaged and they got married. Aw. So look at that Tinder button, the Tinder wrap up. See, that could have been Michael Scott. Right. But you know what? Michael probably would have done what my nephew did on the first pass and put a photo of like him and a random celebrity he had met. Well,
当时吓坏了，超级尴尬。他立刻删除了照片，说他真的很尴尬。是他的朋友说服他用那个钩子的。但你猜怎么着？这个故事有一个可爱的结尾。几年后，他确实用一张只有他自己的精彩照片遇到了一个女孩。他们开始约会，订婚并结婚了。噢。所以看看那个Tinder结尾，Tinder的总结。你看，那本来可能是迈克尔·斯科特。没错。但你知道吗？迈克尔可能第一步就会做我侄子做的事，放一张他和某个他见过的随机名人的合影。好吧，
instead, Michael is now in line for a second nightclub. And they're going to run into some problems because they are not allowed to go inside this nightclub unless they have dates. So they're going to team up with a woman's basketball team. The Jersey State varsity basketball team looked it up. No such thing. We had a fan question from Cat F. Were the women in line for the nightclub actually basketball players? And if so, were they on a team together in real life? No, they were not a basketball team. They were all hired background performers. They were hired through central casting. Now the woman
相反，迈克尔现在正在排队等候第二家夜店。他们会遇到一些问题，因为除非有女伴，否则他们不被允许进入这家夜店。所以他们要和一支女子篮球队组队。泽西州立大学校队。我查过了。没这回事。我们收到了凯特·F的粉丝提问。排队等候夜店的那些女性真的是篮球运动员吗？如果是的话，她们在现实生活中是同一个队的吗？不，她们不是篮球队。她们都是雇来的背景演员。她们是通过中央选角公司雇佣的。现在那个
that Dwight ends up kissing, she had a speaking role. Her name was Cassie Fleagle. And she auditioned for the role through Alison Jones. And she was a former basketball player. But I guess the casting notice said they were looking for people who were six foot one or taller. And she is only, I mean, I'm putting only in quotes, five foot 11. But she still got the role because her audition was so good. Well, she looked very tall to me, especially with her heels on. Yeah. But everyone looks very tall to me. So maybe I'm not a good judge. Well, back in the parking lot, folks are getting restless. Toby finds
德怀特最后亲吻的女人，她有台词。她叫卡西·弗莱格尔。她是通过艾莉森·琼斯试镜得到这个角色的。她曾是一名篮球运动员。但我猜选角通知上说他们寻找身高6英尺1英寸或更高的人。而她只有，我是说，我把“只有”加了引号，5英尺11英寸。但她还是得到了这个角色，因为她的试镜太棒了。好吧，她在我看来很高，尤其是穿着高跟鞋的时候。是的。但每个人在我看来都很高。所以也许我不是个好的评判者。好吧，回到停车场，大家开始变得焦躁不安。托比发现
a football wants to know if Pam wants to toss the old ball. And she's like, Oh, yeah, I know how to throw a football. He's like, Of course you do. Because he's completely enamored with her. I know. Of course you do. What? Yeah. Of course, you do. You're a cool girl. You know how to throw a football. You probably can change a tire. Guess what she can. Well, Pam does throw the football right into Meredith's face. We got some mail about this from Rohit out who wanted to know how did we do this scene? Did you really hit Kate in the face with a ball? And if so, how many times did you have to film it? Let me tell you, I rewatched this
了一个橄榄球，想知道帕姆想不想扔扔球。她说，哦，是的，我知道怎么扔橄榄球。他说，当然你知道。因为他完全被她迷住了。我知道。当然你知道。什么？是的。当然，你知道。你是个酷女孩。你知道怎么扔橄榄球。你可能还会换轮胎。你猜怎么着，她确实会。好吧，帕姆确实把橄榄球直接扔到了梅雷迪斯的脸上。我们收到了罗希特·奥关于这件事的邮件，他想知道我们是怎么拍这个场景的？你真的用球砸了凯特的脸吗？如果是的话，你们拍了多少次？让我告诉你，我和我女儿伊莎贝尔重看了这一集。
episode with my daughter, Isabel. And I had forgotten about that moment when it happened. We were both like, And Isabel said, Mom, I think she really got hit in the face. It looks like she got hit in the face. And I said, Isabel, no way. There is no way they threw a football at Kate's face. So I texted Kate. And I said, Kate, Isabel thinks you really got hit in the face with that football. And she said, Isabel's not wrong. And I said, Kate, you have to send in an audio clip about this moment. And she did. Here it is. Hey, it's Kate Flannery. There's a scene where Pam throws the football to Andy
我当时已经忘了那一刻发生的事了。我们俩都说，伊莎贝尔说，妈妈，我觉得她真的被砸到脸了。看起来就像她被砸到脸了。我说，伊莎贝尔，不可能。他们不可能把橄榄球扔到凯特的脸上。所以我给凯特发了短信。我说，凯特，伊莎贝尔认为你真的被那个橄榄球砸到脸了。她说，伊莎贝尔没说错。我说，凯特，你必须发一段关于这一刻的音频片段。她照做了。这是音频。嘿，我是凯特·弗兰纳里。有一个场景是帕姆把橄榄球扔给安迪
in the parking lot, but Meredith's face gets in the way. And for some reason, I was insistent on doing my own stunt. There was a stunt double there, but she did not work that night. For some reason, I thought it was funnier. It's always funnier to me when an actor can do their own stunt. But I didn't realize where the camera was. And my back was sorted to the camera. So it kind of could have been anybody. Yeah. But I will say they deflated the ball a little bit, which was supposed to help. But I don't remember Ken Whittingham was directing. And I just remember, I think we did eight takes and we weren't done. We weren't done. And I
在停车场，但梅雷迪斯的脸挡住了。出于某种原因，我坚持要自己做特技。现场有一个特技替身，但她那天晚上没工作。出于某种原因，我觉得那样更有趣。对我来说，演员能自己做特技总是更有趣。但我没意识到摄像机在哪里。我的背对着摄像机。所以那个人可能是任何人。是的。但我得说他们把球放掉了一点气，这本该有帮助。但我记得肯·惠廷汉姆在执导。我只记得，我想我们拍了八次，还没拍完。还没拍完。而且我
just kind of felt like after the eight, when we hit number eight, I was like, this was a really stupid idea. And I slept really well that night. I don't think I had a concussion or anything, but I had the weirdest dreams. It was kind of exhausting. And yeah, don't try this at home, kids. Okay, Ange, I want to lead with it's not the same as being the person who's getting hit in the face with the ball. But it is not fun to be the person who has to throw a ball at their friend's face eight times. Eight balls to the face. That sounds wrong. But you know what I mean. That's eight balls. Well, I would throw it and I
拍到第八次的时候，我就觉得，这真是个愚蠢的主意。那天晚上我睡得很好。我不认为我脑震荡什么的，但我做了最奇怪的梦。这有点让人筋疲力尽。是的，孩子们，别在家里尝试这个。好吧，安吉，我想先说，这和被球砸到脸的人是不一样的。但作为一个不得不八次把球扔向朋友脸的人，这并不好玩。八个球砸脸。这听起来不对劲。但你知道我的意思。那是八个球。好吧，我会扔它，而且我
was trying to make it not that hard hitting her face. And you know, that was probably one of the reasons why we had to do so many takes because eventually Ken got me aside and said, Jenna, you need to throw the ball in her face because it's hitting her lightly. And we just need one where you hit her in the face with the ball. And I was like, Oh my gosh, well, you have to believe that Pam knows how to throw a football. You have to sell it. So you would have chunked it. But man, Kate saying, you know what, I want you to hit me in the face. Thank you for providing a stunt double. But I'll take this one for the team. Yeah, way to go, Jenna. She had
试图让它砸到她脸上时不要那么用力。你知道，这可能就是我们不得不拍那么多次的原因之一，因为最后肯把我拉到一边说，珍娜，你需要把球扔到她脸上，因为它砸得太轻了。我们只需要一个你用球砸到她脸的镜头。我说，天哪，好吧，你必须相信帕姆知道怎么扔橄榄球。你必须演出来。所以你会用力扔。但天哪，凯特说，你知道吗，我想要你砸我的脸。谢谢你提供特技替身。但我会为团队承担这一次。是的，干得好，珍娜。她做了
weird dreams way to go. I know I'm sorry. Well, back in the club number two, Michael thinks he's met the love of his life. In fact, he wants to introduce her to his mom. He's so happy. And the camera operator kind of gives a little nod. She's over chatting someone else up. Yeah. And I was like, Oh my gosh, here's the camera getting involved. I feel like the documentary crew normally does this with Pam and not so much with Michael. Yeah, it was nice that they sort of helped Michael not go too far down that imaginary relationship road. We've already done that with the chair model. So let's just Michael will dose a reality. Take it
奇怪的梦，干得好。我知道，我很抱歉。好吧，回到二号夜店，迈克尔认为他遇到了他一生的挚爱。事实上，他想把她介绍给他妈妈。他太高兴了。摄像师点了一下头。她正在和别人聊天。是的。我说，天哪，摄像机介入了。我觉得纪录片组通常会对帕姆这样做，而不是对迈克尔。是的，他们某种程度上帮助迈克尔不要在那个虚构的关系道路上走得太远，这很好。我们已经对椅子模特做过那样的事了，所以迈克尔还是面对现实吧。放轻松。
easy. Yeah. Well, Ryan, meanwhile, is talking about an impending nuclear Holocaust and jungle warfare. And then he takes the dance floor and starts dancing like a crazy person and like shoves a girl and she shoves him back. And now it's looking like it's going to be a brawl. Michael's talking to his mom as you do in the club, right? And he's like, Mom, I got to go. My friend's getting beaten up by some girls. Well, have you know, Angela, we did employ a stunt person to do those fight scenes with Ryan. So all good there. All of these shenanigans lead to the group getting escorted out of the club. Troy makes a
是的。好吧，瑞安同时在谈论即将到来的核大屠杀和丛林战争。然后他走上舞池，开始像个疯子一样跳舞，还推了一个女孩，她又推了他。现在看起来要打架了。迈克尔正在和他妈妈说话，就像你在夜店里做的那样，对吧？他说，妈，我得走了。我朋友被几个女孩打了。好吧，你知道吗，安吉拉，我们确实雇了一名特技演员来拍那些和瑞安打架的场景。所以一切都好。所有这些恶作剧导致这群人被护送出了夜店。特洛伊
run for it, says, Hey, don't take him to a hospital and literally runs away. Yes. Well, we had to ask Noel what it was like to just shoot all of these club scenes. This was really an epic shoot. And here's what he had to say. Shooting the nightclub scenes were fun to do. I don't really remember any kind of improvising during those few scenes in the night out episode. There was no really breaking character. I tried to stay professional and the only kind of stuff that was funny during the scenes was the scenes with BJ and Steve, where he says, why won't the girls let me dance? And I would get a lot of recognition
跑了，说，嘿，别把他带到医院，然后真的跑开了。是的。好吧，我们不得不问诺埃尔拍摄所有这些夜店场景是什么感觉。这真是一次史诗般的拍摄。这是他要说的话。拍摄夜店场景很有趣。我不记得在《夜出》这一集的那些场景中有任何即兴发挥。没有真正打破角色。我尽量保持专业，唯一在场景中好笑的事情是和BJ以及史蒂夫的场景，他说，为什么女孩们不让我跳舞？我得到了很多认可
from my don't take him to a hospital line where I'm like running down the dark alley. But another fun story was later, there was a day where we ended up shooting quite late and they had actually dismissed Steve Carell. And I was left last on set shooting a monologue at past midnight. And that day I had a 7 a.m. call if I was dead tired shooting this monologue over and over again, which we did eventually get. But leaving at 1 a.m. or so was quite interesting that day. Well, I really relate to what Noel said here because many times I had talking heads at the end of the day and you're so tired and half of the cast has gone
因为我那句“别把他带到医院”的台词，当时我正跑在黑暗的小巷里。但另一个有趣的故事是后来，有一天我们拍得相当晚，他们实际上已经让史蒂夫·卡瑞尔下班了。我是最后一个留在片场拍独白的，拍到了午夜之后。那天我早上7点就有通告，我累得要死，一遍又一遍地拍这个独白，我们最终拍到了。但凌晨1点左右离开那天确实很有趣。好吧，我真的能体会诺埃尔在这里说的话，因为很多时候我在一天结束时有采访镜头，你太累了，一半的演员已经
home and you're trying to focus. But yes, if you go to the deleted scenes, there's a talking head by Troy where he totally denies his role in helping Ryan get drugs. Well, we were also curious, Angela, to hear how often does Noel get recognized from being on the office because he was in several episodes. And here's what he had to say. Oh, the big question. Do I get recognized? But I do get recognized here and there at Starbucks or even during outings with my family when I'm just going to a dinner at a restaurant, a busboy will even say, weren't you on the office if it is just kind of a crack up to me. But I think
回家了，你还在努力集中注意力。但是的，如果你去看删减片段，有一个特洛伊的采访镜头，他完全否认了他在帮助瑞安获取毒品中的角色。好吧，安吉拉，我们也很好奇，诺埃尔因为出演《办公室》被认出来的频率有多高，因为他出演了好几集。这是他要说的话。哦，大问题。我会被认出来吗？但我确实在这里或那里被认出来，在星巴克，甚至在和家人外出时，当我只是去餐厅吃晚饭，一个服务生甚至会说，你不是《办公室》里的那个人吗？这对我来说简直太搞笑了。但我认为
the furthest recognition I got was a vacation trip to Hawaii and a young lady in a store was actually chatting with my mom and asked if her son was on the office and she was all excited and actually asked me to come back and get a picture with her, which is a blast to do. It's just kind of funny to me. But I'm always open to like signing autographs or taking pictures with fans. I actually quite enjoy it. And I just loved everything about the office. It was so much fun to do. But I always loved being around everybody. So sweet. So sweet. Back in the lobby, Hank is still not there. He hasn't even
我得到的最远距离的认可是去夏威夷度假，店里的一位年轻女士实际上在和我妈妈聊天，问她的儿子是不是在《办公室》里，她非常兴奋，甚至让我回去和她合影，这太棒了。这对我来说很有趣。但我总是乐于给粉丝签名或合影。我实际上很享受。我真的很喜欢《办公室》的一切。拍起来太有趣了。但我总是喜欢和大家在一起。太甜了。太甜了。回到大厅，汉克还没到。他甚至还没
left his house yet. I would dare to say Hank is in no hurry to go get them. No. Meanwhile in the lobby, Toby is crackin' the jokes, feeling pretty good about himself. Yeah. Pam is laughing at Toby's jokes. And he is so pleased with himself that without knowing it, he puts his hand on Pam's knee and then like kind of strokes it with one finger, like his index finger. He kind of does a little swipey swipey back and forth. And everyone clocks it. It is so cringey and awkward. So then Toby announces very
离开家。我敢说汉克一点也不急着去接他们。不。与此同时在大厅里，托比在讲笑话，对自己感觉相当不错。是的。帕姆在笑托比的笑话。他对自己非常满意，以至于在不知不觉中，他把手放在了帕姆的膝盖上，然后用一根手指抚摸它，就像他的食指。他来回轻轻地划了一下。每个人都注意到了。这太尴尬了。所以托比突然宣布
suddenly that he's moving to Costa Rica. He runs out the door, hops the fence, and jogs home. Hops the fence? This is no hop the fence type of fence. I rewatch this. This is a scaling over a wall type of fence. It is really tall. When did Toby get so athletic? I also did screen grab. You can clearly see the stuntman. All right. Well, we got some fan mail about that from Emily Abbey, Christy and Ellie. Was that really Paul Lieberstein jumping over the fence?
他要搬到哥斯达黎加。他跑出门，跳过栅栏，慢跑回家。跳过栅栏？这不是那种跳过栅栏的栅栏。我重看了。这是一种攀爬墙壁式的栅栏。它真的很高。托比什么时候变得这么运动了？我也截了图。你可以清楚地看到特技演员。好吧。好吧，我们收到了艾米丽、艾比、克里斯蒂和艾莉关于这件事的粉丝邮件。真的是保罗·利伯斯坦跳过栅栏的吗？
No. I reached out to Paul and Paul told me that he was willing to do it. He offered to try, but they explained that we would have to shoot the scene multiple times, which increased the possibility for injury. And so they insisted on hiring a stunt person. He also said, quote, obviously I'm a guy who does his own stunts, but I had to put the show first. Well, Paul, I get it. You wanted to do it. They said no. So you had to do what they said. I want to say something, Angela. I remember that we shot this scene
不。我联系了保罗，保罗告诉我他愿意做。他主动提出尝试，但他们解释说我们必须多次拍摄这个场景，这增加了受伤的可能性。所以他们坚持雇佣一名特技演员。他还说，引用，“显然我是一个自己做特技的人，但我必须把节目放在第一位。”好吧，保罗，我明白了。你想做。他们说不。所以你必须做他们说的。我想说点什么，安吉拉。我记得我们拍这个场景
very, very late on a Friday night. It was like 2 a.m. And I think that that also increases the risk of injury. I think you should not attempt to do your own stunts at 2 a.m. So I think it was a wise move, especially one that involves basically scaling something that's one story high. I mean, I'm exaggerating, but it's a really tall fence. It really is. He could have easily twisted an ankle or broken an arm. We had a fan theory by Carolyn G. Since Toby jumps the fence with such apparent ease,
是在周五晚上非常非常晚的时候。大概是凌晨2点。我认为这也增加了受伤的风险。我认为你不应该尝试在凌晨2点做自己的特技。所以我认为这是一个明智的举动，尤其是涉及基本攀爬一层楼高的东西。我是说，我在夸张，但这确实是一个非常高的栅栏。它确实是。他很容易扭伤脚踝或摔断胳膊。我们收到了卡罗琳·G的粉丝理论。既然托比跳过栅栏显得如此轻松，
it shows that he's someone who might be able to escape the police. Is this added evidence that Toby is the Scranton Strangler? I asked Paul about this. His response was sound smart. Mm-hmm. Dun dun dun. Perhaps if you were the Scranton Strangler, you might have to set up residence outside of the country. Wow. That's a good point. Just saying. Well, hold up. What's happening? The cleaning crew has arrived. Yes. And the cleaning crew lets them out. Everyone is thrilled. Still no hank. Oh, well, we'll get to that.
这表明他可能是一个能够逃脱警察追捕的人。这是托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手的额外证据吗？我问了保罗这个问题。他的回答听起来很聪明。嗯哼。当当当。也许如果你是斯克兰顿勒杀手，你可能不得不搬到国外居住。哇。那是个好观点。只是说说而已。好吧，等等。发生了什么？清洁工到了。是的。清洁工把他们放了出来。每个人都很激动。还是没有汉克。哦，好吧，我们会谈到的。
Mm-hmm. Meanwhile, back in New York, the guys arrive at Ryan's apartment and Dwight and Michael, they're going to crash there for the night. They're kind of fighting over the sofa. Well, I want to say something about this apartment. It looks like a one-bedroom studio. And I really appreciated that because I always thought the apartments on the show Friends were ridiculous. I lived in New York. No one could afford those things. No. So I appreciated that Ryan had a very modest apartment in New York. I mean, it was very messy, but I'd like to
嗯哼。与此同时，回到纽约，他们到达了瑞安的公寓，德怀特和迈克尔要在那里过夜。他们有点在争沙发。好吧，我想说点关于这个公寓的事。它看起来像个一居室工作室。我真的很欣赏这一点，因为我一直认为美剧《老友记》里的公寓很荒谬。我住在纽约。没人买得起那些房子。不。所以我很欣赏瑞安在纽约有一个非常简朴的公寓。我是说，它非常乱，但我喜欢
point out at 18 minutes 59 seconds. He's got an enormous flat screen TV. Hmm. Yeah. I wish we could have had a moment where Michael clocks that. Me too. And like, maybe it was on an arm and he pulled it out and it actually went further than two inches. That would have been amazing. Well, Dwight is going to sing Ryan a lullaby. And we had a fan question about it, Angela, from Cameron D and Joe S. Did the writers make up the lullaby that Dwight sings to Ryan? Or is it real? I think Rain improvised that moment. That's my guess. It's so much better than that. What? This is a real lullaby? And our script
指出在18分59秒。他有一个巨大的平板电视。嗯。是的。我希望我们能有一个迈克尔注意到这一点的时刻。我也是。就像，也许它在支架上，他把它拉出来，它实际上伸出了超过两英寸。那会很棒。好吧，德怀特要给瑞安唱摇篮曲。我们收到了关于它的粉丝提问，安吉拉，来自卡梅伦·D和乔·S。编剧们编造了德怀特唱给瑞安的摇篮曲吗？还是真实的？我想雷恩即兴发挥了那一刻。这是我的猜测。它比那好多了。什么？这是一首真正的摇篮曲？我们的剧本
supervisor, Vada, taught it to Rain. Amazing. Yes. It was one that her Austrian grandmother used to sing to her. But here is something that Mindy revealed in an interview. She said they never found out what the words meant. Vada just wrote it out phonetically for Rain right before the scene. So he could be singing like some creepy stuff. We don't know. Okay. As Ryan is going to sleep, he tells them he thinks his friend Troy might have a drug problem and I think we all know who he's talking about. Michael gives him horrible advice and then looks to Cameron says, best night ever. Yeah. Michael has a talking head where he said,
主管瓦达教给雷恩的。太棒了。是的，这是她奥地利祖母过去常唱给她听的。但这里有一些明迪在采访中透露的事情。她说他们从来没弄清楚歌词是什么意思。瓦达就在场景前为雷恩用拼音写了下来。所以他可能在唱一些令人毛骨悚然的东西。我们不知道。好吧。当瑞安去睡觉时，他告诉他们他认为他的朋友特洛伊可能有毒品问题，我想我们都知道他在说谁。迈克尔给了他糟糕的建议，然后看着卡梅伦说，有史以来最好的夜晚。是的。迈克尔有一个采访镜头，他说，
you know, this whole time in his life, it's not the horniness, it's the loneliness. But how could he be lonely when he's with his voice? Like a famous person once said, boys on the side, let's hear it for the boys. Well, I would not want to be Jim Halpert on Monday because Hank shows up, sees that none of them are there and goes, son of a bitch. You know, I did have to wonder Angela, did Hank not notice all of their cars in the parking lot when he chained it for the night? Or was he just like, listen, these guys didn't give me a bonus? I don't know. I'm leaving. There's probably a bit of that. They didn't call me. They didn't
你知道，他生命中的这段时间，不是因为好色，而是因为孤独。但他和他的声音在一起时怎么会孤独呢？就像一位名人曾经说过的，男孩在身边，让我们为男孩们欢呼吧。好吧，我可不想在周一做吉姆·哈珀特，因为汉克出现了，看到他们都不在那里，然后说，狗娘养的。你知道，我确实不得不怀疑，安吉拉，汉克在晚上锁门时没注意到他们所有的车都在停车场吗？还是他只是想，听着，这些人没给我奖金？我不知道。我要走了。可能有一点那种成分。他们没给我打电话。他们没
give me a bonus. I'm out of here. I'm out of here. Good luck, A-holes. Well, that was night out, you guys. Thank you so much for sending in your questions and your comments. Yeah. Thank you to Kate Flannery and to Noel Petock for sending in your audio clips. And to Terry Carnation. Terry, you were supposed to leave our Zoom. I've been here the whole time. Cassie, Cassie. It's been a delightful conversation. I'm definitely going to watch this episode of television. It looks fantastic, but my theory holds up. The building is definitely possessed. All right. Well, okay. Cassie. Thank you for listening to the Office Women podcast. This is Terry Carnation, host of Dark Air with Terry Carnation. You've been wonderful. We'll see you
给我奖金。我走了。我走了。祝你们好运，混蛋们。好吧，那就是《夜出》，你们这些家伙。非常感谢你们发来的问题和评论。是的。感谢凯特·弗兰纳里和诺埃尔·佩托克发来的音频片段。还有特里·卡内申。特里，你本该离开我们的Zoom的。我一直都在这儿。卡西，卡西。这是一次愉快的谈话。我一定会看这一集电视。它看起来棒极了，但我的理论成立。这栋楼绝对闹鬼。好吧，好吧。卡西。感谢收听《办公室女士》播客。我是特里·卡内申，《特里·卡内申的黑暗空气》主持人。你们太棒了。我们下周见，
next week, guys. Cassie hit the button. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伙计们。卡西，按那个按钮。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码：OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。